When I'm really desperate for something salty
I’ll grab maybe a pickle or bag of potato
chips, but macaws, they grab a big old hunk
of dirt.
All animals need salt, badly, for
basic biological function.
Animals in the western Amazon are really deprived of salt
because the Andes actually block the weather
from the Pacific. So that means that all of
the weather comes from the Atlantic. By the
time that salty air gets all the way to the
western Amazon, most of that salt has already
fallen.
So animals in the western Amazon are
really desperate for salt, and they'll go
to great lengths to get it. Macaws, in particular,
which are specialized for fruit in the very
highest part of the canopy will come all the
way down and they'll eat the dirt. They’re
selecting these very specific layers of soil
that were formed over geological time during
periods where conditions were a little bit
saltier than in the other times. It’s like
a vitamin, but it’s especially salty.